my dirt is I'm super not interested in
being fancy I'm willing to work I work
harder than everybody in this room and I
swear on my [ __ ] life I'm positive
because you can only tie me be and so
I'm just not fancy like I'm gonna win
and I'm gonna continue to win and I'm
gonna be real [ __ ] big and I'm never
gonna forget what I'm about and I like
getting my hands dirty and I'll answer
that email and I'll stop and have that
conversation and I'll take that pitch
and I do unscalable not the right use of
my time [ __ ] 50% of my day every day for
the rest of my life cuz I love the
[ __ ] dirt I love the grind I'll never
get fancy
I don't like fancy and so that's
important to me because I apologize
because because I want to clarify one
thing about the dirt because it's
important because you need to be a
practitioner to be good at what you do I
don't wanna be a social media guru that
reads a headline from somebody else's to
me I know every [ __ ] thing that
musically snapchat vine Facebook Twitter
Instagram does period and I sit with all
these gurus that sell [ __ ] books to
and all these [ __ ] social media
experts and corporations and starts I
send the [ __ ] Facebook and Instagram
in meetings where their executives are
wrong like I'm a [ __ ] practitioner I
really know my [ __ ] and that's important
if you want to win you have to be able
to do that and way too many people lose
that they forget what gets them there
and they're not keeping up with it and
the thing that I do for a living is hard
because these platforms are changing
every day every second and a lot of
things change and the things that were
tried and true a week ago change and in
that arbitrage in your headline reading
I make money
you